okay now our next guest Caroline Flint
represents an area which voted strongly
to leave the EU and when I visited Don
Valley last October there were certainly
no mood for a second referendum then so
let's find out what Caroline Flint makes
of a party's decision to back another
vote thank you for being with us this
morning so how do you think Labour's
position is going to go down in your
constituency
well Labor's position is still to seek
an improved offer in fact John MacDonald
early on said we need a great British
compromise and I agree with him it's not
about a Tory deal it's actually not
about a Labour deal it's about an
improved brexit deal and myself and so
many Labour MPs in the general election
2017 made a promise to our voters to
respect the outcome of the referendum
and that was Labour's policy so my
appeal to John MacDonald to Jeremy
Corbyn tackiest Armour is allow MPs to
have a free vote on an improved deal so
those MPs who want a second very friend
and can vote for that but those of us
who want to keep our promises to our
electorate can also keep faith with
those people and vote for an improved
deal and secondly to my labour
colleagues it is about an improved deal
and if you want to support a transition
period if you want to make sure you
Nationals rights are maintained if you
want to make sure as some of us have
been negotiating for an improved workers
rights offer but more importantly make
sure we don't go out without a deal
I urge my labour colleagues to consider
voting for an improved deal it's
interesting to talk about voting for an
improved deal here does that mean that
you are seriously considering voting in
favor of the deal that reason may comes
back with well we already have on the
table a deal that protects EU Nationals
and more has been added to that since
the vote in January the waiving of fees
for example we are have been in
negotiation and discussion about an
improved offer workers rights and what
that means for your listeners is as we
leave the European Union we maintain
those employment rights health and
safety rights environmental standards
that we currently share but going
forward we make sure that Parliament
consider can consider that where those
rights are
moved by the European Union we debate it
in Parliament and vote on it to see if
we want to adopt those rights and I
think that's important it is one of the
key red lines that Labour had in terms
of its negotiations with the government
I urge the front bench of the Labour
Party to continue putting on the
pressure as those of us have been doing
to secure that as we come to the vote on
an improved deal next week so if you get
those assurances on workers rights will
you vote for Tories amazed oh well I
have you I've got to see it before I
believe it but we have been negotiating
for those sets of conditions and if an
improved deal comes back and that is
guaranteed if we are going into a
situation of a transition where we can
go into detail to discuss in more detail
trade and security arrangements EU
Nationals being protected but
importantly more than anything else I
don't support bowing out without a deal
and if it's a choice between an improved
deal and no deal I think we should
seriously consider supporting an
improved deal and that is that
represents the principles behind my
voting and my approach to this whole
debate over the last thousand days how
many other Labour MPs do you think are
in the same position is you seriously
considering voting for what you describe
as an improved deal I think there are
many Labour MPs who share my concerns
that not only after the referendum in
did we support Labour Party policy to
respect the result but also we stood on
a manifesto in 2017 whereby Labour said
the decision to leave the European Union
has been settled by the British people
and we will work to secure the best deal
and it is in that spirit that we made
our pledges to our electorate and those
of us who want to stand by that want to
have that respected right now I think
there are something like 60 70 I think
there are something like 60 70 Labour
MPs who feel as strongly as I do against
the second referendum but also I think
it's important to recognize many of
those MPs also feel that we have to move
on we have to stop a No Deal and if
there's an improved offer on the
Abell labor should engage with that
sincerely as I've said before Sophie
this isn't about a Tory deal or a labor
deal this is about trying to secure an
improved brexit deal and allow us to
move forward because I want to and I
know this is shared by many of my labor
colleagues we want to get on to the
domestic policies that we feel haven't
been addressed in the last thousand days
because of the brexit discussion and I
think we need to get onto that front
because I think therein lies the
opportunity for labour to make inroads
to secure the next general election and
breakfast is stopping us doing it and if
we if we are seen to not keep our
promises that we made then I think that
bodes ill for the Labor Party
so just to be really trying pushy
because I think it is quite important I
mean how many MPs do you think Labour
MPs do you think could potentially vote
for a deal when it comes back to
Parliament well I think that all depends
on the front bench I think if there was
a free vote a number a number Ten's
2030s would vote for an improved offer I
think that's the reality the problem is
here is that we are being asked to break
our promises under a whipping system
that does not allow us to keep faith
with our electorate now look brexit has
divided the country it has divided
parties it divided the Labour Party so
my appeal to Jeremy to Kier is allow us
to have on this big issue a free vote so
those who want to stop brexit those who
want to have a second referendum can
vote for that but those of us who want
to keep faith with our promises that
we've made can also keep faith with
those pledges too and I believe to that
end a free vote is absolutely
justifiable now we know that many labour
and peas are really agonizing about the
state of the labour party right now
whether that's because of concerns over
brexit or anti-semitism and I just
wonder what your position is about the
assessment of the health of the labour
party right now this year Sophie I have
been a member of the Labour Party for 40
years I joined in 1979 and I would have
to say
on the issue of anti-semitism I have
never known anything like it in terms of
people who seem to have come into our
party with hardcore anti-semitic views
the last three years is has just shown
that this is a phenomena that has not
been there in the Labor Party before and
I'm not just saying that any see member
John Landsman who founded momentum is
saying it too and to that end I think
the Labour Party whilst it has improved
its structures to deal with this it's
not really a structural problem in that
sense it's an action problem and what I
want to see is these whether it's a
couple of hundred or more hardcore
anti-semites kicked out of our party and
that needs to be done effectively and
quickly I mean I know you have very
different views on brexit to the
independent group who split from the
Labour Party but do you ever look across
there in Austin he quit the party to sit
as an independent and think I understand
why you did that and I could be tempted
to do the same no I won't be tempted to
do the same but let me say this when
people like Luciana burger Joan Ryan a a
friend of mine and still a friend of
mine when in Austin left the Labour
Party actually mike gates as well who
I've known for many many many years that
was a week of sorrow to see those
colleagues go I don't agree with them
obviously it's clear on the brexit issue
and I have in Austin I have more common
ground on that matter but I think more
than anything else that stands out is
the bullying the racism and intimidation
that my friend and colleague Luciana
Berger suffered was absolutely
unacceptable and the party should have
stood up much much earlier to deal with
that and last for the last two weeks
have been a should be seen as a time of
sorrow for the Labour Party and we have
to think about why those members left
rather than in some quarters being
triumphant about it our party is a
broadchurch to be honest as social
reformers who want social justice we
were founded to achieve that we were
found
to achieve that through winning seats to
gain power through government and for
our party we need to make sure that we
recognize that this sort of disruption
this sort of factionism this
sectarianism will not help Jeremy Corbyn
win a general election